[Music]
this is a National Emergency
didn't need a charge
[Music]
we're in a race against the Nazis
and I know what it means
if the Nazis have a bomb
I have a 12-month Head Start 18. how
could you possibly know that
we've got one hope
all America's industrial minded
scientific innovation connected here
secret Laboratory
keep everyone there until it's dark
let's go recruit some scientists
build a town build it fast
there's only scientists ring their
families will never get the best
why would we go to the middle of nowhere
for who knows how long
why why
because this is the most important thing
to ever happen in the history of the
world
you're the great improviser but this
you can't do in your head
are we saying there's a chance that when
we push that button
destroy the world chances are near zero
near zero what do you want for Theory
alone zero would be nice
this is a matter of life and death
but I can perform this miracle
World War II would be over our boys
would come home
that's happening isn't it
[Music]
World
well remember this day
[Applause]
I work here
will ensure peace mankind is never seen
[Music]
until somebody builds a bigger one
you are the man who gave them the power
to destroy themselves
and the world is not prepared
hey
seven
six five
four
three Truman needs to know what's next
what's next